we've discussed your wife before lovely
lovely young named Lydia you never
married for how long almost two years
very nice how is how are you finding now
uh no crab not on board for that it
turns out you know what 80 percent we're
like no marriage is a sham like people
not on board I think it's you get a
round of applause if you Andy how long
have you married 24 years yeah that's
that's really good yeah yeah you don't
really get the applause until the sex
stop that was a very medium response
well it was in proportion to Andy's
that's like a hundred years but I did
get to have a very special I don't know
if you guys remember this moment but I
was driving home from work last fall and
my wife Lydia calls me and she says hey
can you swing by the store and pick me
up some tampons and I was like yeah well
yeah because I was excited this was an
exciting rite of passage a marriage is
an archetypal task and I'm not like it's
like holding the purse it's like one of
the things it's one of those things
that's up there with you you know you
hold the purse you go and you get the
tampon yeah yeah yeah yeah so it was
very exciting she was like pick up some
some tampons and some onions and I'm
like great two things that make you cry
the tampon absorbs all the extra oil
stir it it goes without saying yeah yeah
yeah BAM so so she said and I was very
excited about by it it's natural it's
beautiful its feminine it's wonderful so
great so I was like too excited though
like I went to the store like tampons
tampons tampons tampons tampons like a
where are the tampons and they're like
they're over in the health department
I'm like it would have been funnier to
put him by the hotdog buns but it's your
store so so I marched over she gave me a
very specific brand of tampon and I did
not want to fail this quest so I go
the tampon aisle and I'm looking at my
tampons tampons and I'm not finding them
and I'm starting to freak out and sweat
that I'm gonna fail this quest yes and
it's not like a clothing store you can't
just two passing women go oh you're
about my wife's eyes can you try it like
you can't do that and so and so I just
grabbed everything I just grabbed all
the tampons like everything just variety
packs everything and I plunk them all
down and I get yeah well sometimes when
he picks it up they probably thought you
were a tampon reviewer yeah
I started the website so I get him home
and I like kick the front door open I
have all these time I was like here the
Tampa and all of a sudden I hear
surprise my it was a week before my
birthday and my wife was throwing a
surprise party
sent me wait a minute listen to this
[ __ ] sent me to a grocery store knowing
they did not have that specific brand of
tampons a classic tampon Z scheme I ask
you please use the tampons if you're
gonna make them complete
you